This is historic.
We're the only late night show to have
a full packed audience. That's right.
I asked our viewers to send
in photographs of themselves.
We turned them into cardboard
cutouts. Over 15,000 people
submitted and we packed
our audience tonight.
Here they are 270 people.
It's a full house.
Look at that crown and
Andy Rector is here.
Hi Andy.
Hi Conan.
How's the crowd.
Oh man. These people are pumped
and they smell a lot better
than our normal audience.
Well,
(laughter)
it's a terrible thing to say.
Oh
But accurate.
Yeah.
Yeah. We have the muskiest audience
in late night, right?
Yes, We do.
That's what we advertise.
Yes,
That's
Yeah
That's, that's the kind
of crowd we get.
But you know, this is, this is great.
This I have to say, I'm getting
an energy of this crowd.
I know it's just cardboard.
Right.
But these are real people.
Excited enough to share
their faces with us.
And check them out. Let's take a look.
I'm going to get down here
and talk to the crowd.
Oh, they love it when you do that.
Look how pumped they
are that I'm down here.
Yeah, you have such a
personal touch with people.
I like the confidence of this man.
This is a confident audience member.
Yeah.
He knows who he is.
He's happy with himself.
This guy also dressed up for the show.
Always nice to have someone
from Paddy's Irish Pub.
Yeah.
Yeah. What an original name
for an Irish pub, by the way,
Paddering.
Yeah.
Paddering deal.
Up all night. What's your,
It is interesting that these
are the pictures that people
thought this is the best
representation of me.
Yes!
This person didn't put a lot of time.
Yeah.
To have their photograph.
This is as good as it gets.
You know, this might be
his driver's license photo.
(laughter)
Which I can't say is
probably the best idea.
Always good to wear.
Oh my God. This woman is beautiful.
She's wearing this absolutely
gorgeous, golden, sari
and really spectacular outfit.
And very nice that,
well, I don't, I'm guessing not a couple.
(laughter)
I don't know. Call me crazy,
but I'm saying not a couple.
Love is mysterious though.
Love is mysterious
You never know
Here we have what appears to be
a Catholic priest and I hope
he's asleep in this photograph.
Otherwise,
Wait, let me see that guy.
Otherwise God
Oh my God!
(laughter)
He's either asleep or God rest his soul.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
God rest his soul.
Hi everybody. It's Dead Clergy Night.
(laughter)
Tonight on Late Night Date
Clergy Night
(laughter)
a cat's always a big part of the show.
That seems to be very popular.
We have a cat here who is horrified
to be sitting next to a dead priest
and COVID, is tough for everybody.
But it's especially tough for new moms.
And this woman looks like she's
just going through hell with
this toddler during COVID.
So it was nice that we were able, right?
Oh boy.
It's tough. I sympathize,
Yeah, yeah
I sympathize,
it's tough having young kids,
but to have young kids drink
COVID and then to have to come
to a taping of the show?
Yeah
I'm hoping it's a ventriloquist act.
(laughter)
Because always, it's a bomber.
No, it's really, it is,
it's, I'm just, I'm thrilled.
I'm absolutely thrilled that
everyone participated and we're
going to somehow figure what
happened to the fire marshal.
We're only supposed to have 270 people.
But that's real people.
We're going to try and
pack as many people in here
as possible in the nights to come.
So if you sent in a picture
or still send one in,
cause we're still printing these out.
Yeah.
We can get thousands of
people into this theater.
I'm sensing we're going to get
a complaint from whoever is behind Commie.
Oh, yeah.
We have a six foot six
life-sized Comey.
Yeah, We started when we,
decided to rip off the baseball,
we started with just the cutouts we had,
which was these guys.
Right.
Yeah. We started at the very beginning.
All we had was Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
the father Conrad Bain
from Different Strokes,
a six foot six Commie and four,
count them four Kevin Harts.
Yep.
Because if you buy three,
the fourth one is free.
They throw one in. Yeah.
Yeah, and so
Yeah, that's
That's what we started out with,
but I feel bad because there's
someone sitting behind Commie
Comey is so big. You know what?
And he's blocking their view of the show.
Can you do anything, Andy?
I sure can. I have just the trick.
Oh,
Good thing you always carry your
(buzzing noise)
I love Bader
(Buzzing noise)
Looks Bader, Bader Ginsburg is hiding
Ah!
Can you see him now?
Yes. He looks like
he's from Shaw shank.
That's fantastic
Much, much better.
I have been bringing this jigsaw
to work for like 15 years.
I want to try something now.
Andy check it out to help if this is
Yeah. I mean, there's a,
there's a very obvious joke
there that I'm not going to say
No, no one would make that joke.
No one would make that joke.
(cat sound)
Oh oh
She, you know what?
She doesn't look like it, but she is nuts.
(laughter)
She goes ape shit when you come out here.
I mean, you know what?
This is the person I
always make eye contact
with when I come out
(laughter)
of the real show
This is the reaction that I'm
looking at and wondering why?
Why did you even come to the show?
(laughter)
Why do you even enjoy comedy at all?
Yeah.
You look like you're here
to pass a death sentence
and you've come to a show.
I don't understand.
Yeah,
she is part of a Trade
Delegation in government.
I'm bringing her up with me.
Wow.
You know what?
Sometimes if an audience member
isn't truly being won over,
you can get them by bringing
them up on stage with you.
Does she seem any happier now?
(laughter)
All right, well,
It seems like she's
saying no to your loan.
(laughter)
So nice to be trying to do
comedy while my home loan
is being turned down.
(laughter)